i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
kanye west is way happier now that kim
kardashian and pete davidson broke up at
least that's what our source says
we're told kanye saw the end of keith
coming quote he never took their
relationship seriously or felt good
about pete being around it's been
crystal clear since day one how ye feels
and his reaction on instagram just days
after keith splits says it all the
rapper shared his now deleted post a
fake cover of the new york times with a
fake headline about pete god sent me
from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
of course kanye's no stranger to airing
out his grievances in his music he's
talking mad about me and probably saying
whatever
most men are not trashing
like the mother of their kids like that
publicly as we saw on season one of the
kardashians kim had some pretty strong
feels about kanye airing out his dirty
laundry in music and on social media
specifically about kim moving on and his
disapproval of having pete around their
four kids
wait when i pick them up i feel like
they borrow
back in may yay bared his soul rapping
about their ongoing divorce and custody
battle in a song called true love
wait no hard feelings but these feelings
hard though wait who got the kids and
those what are those wait why they can't
wear yeezys with the cargo but now that
keeps over our source says kanye and kim
have been getting along better recently
and co-parenting in a respectful way
no matter
what we're going through i always want
my kids to
be around their dad as much as possible
but for anyone holding out hope for a
kim yay reconciliation don't hold your
breath we're told kim ye is still moving
ahead with their divorce but things are
peaceful between the two kim's attorney
laura wasser was in court last week and
told the judge kim and kanye are getting
along and are in communication you just
gotta roll with it
[Music]